as the kids head back to school it's
time to get that summer dust dirt and
traffic out and get back to clean and no
one does that better than our friends
from xerorez the sponsors of this
segment and joining me to tell us more
is one of the owners ben mckee welcome
back and brother doug you guys this is a
family business and i love how you guys
run it because you truly take care of
your customers they mean everything to
you absolutely and we love las vegas
we've been in vegas for nearly i don't
know i've been here for the last 10
years i went to elementary school here
it's like art's our home we love it now
xero rez has been cleaning my home for
probably that long if not longer and
there's something about xero res clean
you don't use soaps you don't use
detergents how do you get your carpet so
clean you know our magic is our
technology we clean with what we call zr
water and this technology eliminates it
eliminates the soaps it eliminates all
the harsh residues that other
traditional methods leave behind and you
get a better clean a safer clean and a
cleanup lasts longer than anything else
it really does last a long time and what
i also love about xero resin tell us a
little bit more about this you don't
just clean carpets you clean a lot of
different things we do if you're looking
to revitalize your tile and grout
upholstery
stone air ducts we clean it all
our approach is we have a service for
every surface that you have and that
includes
mattresses if you've never had your
mattress cleaned try it you'd be
surprised at what comes out in there
there's a lot of pollen and allergies in
those things let's talk about pets you
specialize in pet stains too we do we've
got an arsenal of products that safely
and effectively address not only the
odor but also the stains that are left
behind by our fur babies and that that
two-step approach it makes it like it
didn't even happen almost i love seeing
zero resin action we're gonna
take a look here you always bring in the
most disgusting carpet i don't know
where you get this from is this from us
your clients oh yeah we ripped it out
it's disgusting but i love doug you do
your magic swipe and it's just amazing i
and i always say it's the one swipe that
you can see the difference and then
imagine when they go over it a few times
yeah wow look at that that's crazy and
this is our vacuum's hooked up to the
truck's engine so it's like having a 300
horsepower vacuum and you can see right
away with one pass one that almost looks
like it came new from the factory and
you don't do just one pass in the home
you actually do several passes we do we
clean it until it looks good and it's
clean
i am truly in awe now let's say you have
a business and people are coming back
into the workplace maybe they haven't
been there because of the pandemic you
guys do work places too we do we clean
offices casinos hotels we have a
dedicated commercial department and we
run nearly 24 7. so we can accommodate
your schedule uh work around your your
staff and make your place healthy and
hygienic you guys have been voted best
of las vegas for a very long time how
many years have you guys gone i believe
it's four four four years in a row it's
definitely well deserved and when you
guys come on the show you always have a
special offer for our viewers tell us
what you're offering we do right now you
can get your carpets cleaned
it's a great time of year to get them
cleaned
you can get two rooms for only eighty
nine dollars and we're throwing in an
additional twenty percent off pet
treatment so take advantage of it that's
always fantastic thank you guys so much
for coming on the the work speaks for
itself they are the best people and you
can feel safe having them in your home
thank you again to zerorez for
sponsoring this segment take advantage
of their back to school back to clean
special like like you said two rooms of
carpet cleaned for only eighty nine
dollars plus save twenty percent on pet
treatments just call 702 840 3333 or go
online to xerorez las vegas dot com for
more minimums
you